buonasera a tutti ciò che davvero conta
è il nome che si riesce a dare fatti e
non infatti in sé ho deciso di iniziare
questo mio talk con la legge di con
perché questo è il motivo per cui negli
ultimi 20 anni
qualche volta mi sono svegliato felice è
il più delle volte sono andato a dormire
con l'ansia
questo perché a dispetto di chi sostiene
che continu soli fatti il modo in cui
noi li raccontiamo ha il potere di
influenzare quelli che accadranno
sembrano fatte un po banale ma nell'era
dei social network
questo sta per diventare quest'asta
diventare quasi una questione di
sopravvivenza
io mi chiamo luigi maria sono un
filmaker regista di film documentari
oggi vi racconterò come le storie che mi
hanno colpito hanno influenzato le
storie che ho raccontato e l'impatto che
questi e poi hanno avuto sui fatti
avvenire
sono cresciuto sono nato nel 1975 sono
cresciuto un po come i protagonisti di
stranger teams mentre adv parlava di un
mondo diviso in due sull'orlo del
baratro non nucleare
noi giocavamo ai giochi di ruolo come
dennis andrè con guardavo mare di
videocassette e passavamo da rambo e
rocky da
indiana jones a karate kid da film
horror splatter come nightmare alla saga
di star wars
tutte queste storie tutti questi questi
personaggi sono entrati nel mio
immaginario di riferimento
l'immaginario e una scatola che abbiamo
dentro dove mettiamo tutto ciò che ci
colpisce e dalla quale è poi attingiamo
quando dobbiamo prendere le decisioni
che riguardano il futuro più o meno
inconsapevolmente l'immaginario è quello
che caratterizza la nostra specie
diciamo le più grandi scoperte dell'uomo
non sarebbero state date tali senza
l'immaginario perché prima di ogni cosa
qualcuno ha dovuto pensare prima di
renderle possibili
io da piccolo volevo fare lo space
cowboy lo space cowboy per antonomasia e
han solo il pilota del millennium falcon
dell'asta della saga di star wars l'uomo
che viaggiava tra le galassie atterrava
in diversi pianeti vivendo un'avventura
diversa ogni volta poi però ho dovuto
fare i conti con quella realtà
finito il liceo mi sono iscritto a
giurisprudenza e dopo poco più di un
anno avevo capito che quello sarebbe mai
stato il mio lavoro
vi lascio o altri dettagli sulla mia
crisi tardo adolescenziale però a un
certo punto devo aver letto da qualche
parte che se qualcuno riuscivo a fare
una cosa per più di 10 mila volte
diventava bravo a farla ho deciso che
dovevo trovare qualcosa che non mi priva
non mi pesa se ripetere tante volte e
sono tornato a quello che era il mio
sogno da bambino quello che avrei voluto
fare se fossi diventato uno space cowboy
ovvero viaggiare e raccontare storie
così ho iniziato a viaggiare ho cambiato
facoltà e ogni volta che aveva un po di
soldi mi spostavo per cercare di fare
qualcosa da qualche parte erano gli anni
in cui internet stava entrando nelle
nostre case
io ero un appassionato di letteratura e
per testuale che nella mia adolescenza
era alla base dei dei giochi di ruolo e
adesso era diventata l'architettura del
nuovo mondo del world wide web
così per la mia tesi di laurea ho deciso
di produrre un film interattivo un iper
film che era qualcosa di molto simile ai
giochi per la playstation
ma a differenza della maggior parte di
questi non si poteva interagire con le
scelte del personaggio ma soltanto
attraverso il po il punto di vista
attraverso il quale assistere
all'evolversi degli eventi
l'obiettivo era dimostrare che il
giudizio sui personaggi cambiava a
seconda del punto di vista che si
sceglieva bene e male dipendeva dal lato
dal quale si guardava li osservava erano
i primi anni 2000 e diciamo non c'era
nemmeno youtube era già difficile
mettere dei video online quindi non era
una di quelle tesi che ti spalanca va il
mondo del lavoro
però per me è stata importante perché
poi quando sono passato al racconto del
reale
ho sentito una grossa responsabilità
quello che fino a quel momento era stata
una responsabilità dello spettatore
ovvero scegliere da che parte stare e
adesso diventava il mio lavoro il mio
primo film è la storia di un tentativo
di manipolare la realtà attraverso un
racconto che ha avuto esiti disastrosi
nel 1981 le brigate rosse erano in crisi
uno dei loro capi era stato arrestato e
aveva iniziato a parlare aveva
raccontato tutto dove erano i covi chi
erano gli altri capi in poche settimane
la struttura di questa organizzazione
terroristica era stata quasi azzerata
quelli che erano riusciti a scappare
all'arresto a scampare all'arresto
avevo deciso di vendicarsi ma non
potevano dirlo così le brigate rosse
pensavano di essere diverse dalla mafia
pensavano di essere un'alternativa allo
stato e lo stato non si vendica quindi
abbiamo deciso di sequestrare il
fratello del capo nel del capo pentito e
di costringerlo non mettere una verità
che faceva comodo a loro la chiamarono
processo breve da proletario il fratello
del dell'ex capo pentito si chiamava
roberto aveva nulla a che fare con le
brigate rosse
eppure fu costretto ad ammettere davanti
a una telecamera di essere stato uno di
loro questo serviva a quei terroristi
per avere una giustificazione per poi
condannarlo a morte
questa storia ha avuto un epilogo
tragico
poche settimane dopo la morte di roberto
tutti i componenti di quella banda sono
finiti in carcere ma nonostante tutto la
videocassetta con il processo proletario
roberto ha continuato a fare danni anche
molto dopo 30 anni dopo nel paese dove
roberto è nato c'era ancora chi
sosteneva che roberto in qualche modo
solo fosse cercato che la tesi dei dei
terroristi in qualche modo fosse
plausibile
così quando roberta la figlia di roberto
la figlia che roberto non ha mai potuto
conoscere perché nata pochi pochi mesi
dopo la sua morte ha deciso di
incontrare il capo delle br di quelle br
che nel frattempo aveva scontato il suo
debito con la giustizia ho deciso di
seguirla con la telecamera è quello che
è nato da questa revisione di quella
storia è nato un documentario che forse
è quello che più di quello di cui sono
più orgoglioso perché adesso la via dove
roberto è stato sequestrato
ha cambiato nome ci sono storie che
riescono a prendere possesso della vita
di chi le racconta come è successo a
george best
george best e un calciatore iconico
degli anni 60
talmente conico da essere diventato di
essere finito su una banconota da 5
pound george era quello che gli uomini
volevano essere le donne volevano avere
era il simbolo di genio sregolatezza
poteva tutto e non ha rinunciato al
nulla
giorgio è morto nel 2005 per i problemi
legati alla sua dipendenza dall'alcol ma
ancora oggi a distanza di tempo incontro
ragazzi
vent'anni con tatuata tatuata sulla
pelle la sua immagine o frasi come
questa
ho speso la maggior parte dei miei soldi
per alcool donne e macchine veloci il
resto lo sperperato questa frase può far
sorridere ma non se sei il figlio di chi
l'ha raccontata di chi l'ha pronunciata
ho conosciuto calum best del figlio di
george a londra nel 2013
io volevo raccontare la vita cosa ci
fosse dietro uno dei miei personaggi
preferiti
la vita reale di uno dei miei idoli e
calum voleva semplicemente conoscere suo
padre calum è nato negli stati uniti e
tutto quello che sapeva del padre
l'aveva aveva trovato su internet non
devono un vero e proprio rapporto
così abbiamo iniziato a viaggiare per
incontrare le persone che conoscevano la
persona di giorgio e non il personaggio
george best
una delle storie che più mi ha colpito
l'abbiamo trovata in california
george v valley con tutta la famiglia in
quel momento e era stato per un periodo
in un rehab per cercare di smettere di
bere c'era quasi riuscito
tornando a casa dalla sua famiglia si è
fermato per fare rifornimento e ha
incontrato mentre metteva benzina uno
dei suoi fan il cui sogno più grande era
bere una birra insieme al mitico george
best
quella sera
george deciso di essere personaggio e
non l'uomo non è tornato a casa dalla
sua famiglia e ha speso la notte con uno
con uno sconosciuto si è ubriacato con
uno sconosciuto
tutto questo non poteva non avere un
effetto devastante sui suoi cari
calum che nella vita aveva scelto di non
fare il calciatore di non provarci
nemmeno ma di fare il modello
l'unico modo che aveva per sentirsi il
figlio di george best e era di vivere la
sua vita fuori dal campo
allo stesso modo così
calum best di stato per anni una sorta
di party animal un personaggio
abbastanza famoso nel mondo anglosassone
per i suoi eccessi
io non sono sicuro che il nostro film
abbia avuto il reale si è davvero
piaciuto ai fan di george
però sono sicuro di una cosa che se una
storia ha avuto anche è stata buona
anche per una sola persona forse è valsa
la pena raccontarla è così qualche
settimana dopo l'uscita del film sono
stato molto felice di leggere una
dichiarazione di calum in cui definiva
il film terapeutico e è adesso quello
che era il party animo delle notati
londinesi probabilmente starà facendo
yoga da qualche parte poi ci sono storie
che riescono a influenzare la vita di
migliaia di persone
fin dalla nascita l'albinismo è una
disfunzione genetica per cui alcune
persone nascono con una carenza di
melanina la melanina un pigmento che dal
colore alla pelle e la protegge dai
raggi solari in africa già questo
sarebbe un problema ma purtroppo non è
l'unico nel più grande perché per colpa
di alcune leggende ci sono persone che
credono che gli albini siano portatori
di sventura e non basta però perché ci
sono anche altre leggende che
considerano le loro ossa magiche per
questo può capitare che le famiglie di
origine li abbandonino e finiti per
strada vengono assaliti da persone con
il machete che li mutilano per
trasformare le loro ossa in amuleti
portafortuna
così quando ho letto su un giornale che
c'era un istruttore di karate che stava
che voleva insegnare a difesa gli albini
ho messo il suo nome sui social e pochi
mesi dopo sono andate a conoscerlo
[Musica]
lui è gerò maga ma anche se tutti lo
conoscono me black samurai il karate in
africa è una sorta di religione che
garantisce i risultati concreti già
nella vita terrena
le persone si avvicinano al karate si
avvicinano al karate dopo aver subito un
torto per cercare vendetta e più delle
volte però una volta entrate nel dojo
capiscono che l'unico modo per
combattere come senza e jerome è seguire
le regole del karate che in primis
insegnano il rispetto e l'autocontrollo
così persone che avrebbero potuto
diventare dei criminali si trasformano
in benefattori sì perché questa gente è
convinta d'aver ricevuto un dono e vive
il resto della sud della loro vita a
dimostrare ea meritarlo quando ho
chiesto senza e jerome cosa fosse per
lui lo spirito il karate lui mi ha
risposto con le parole che avrebbe
potuto usare yoda il gran maestro
dell'ordine geni per descrivere la forza
e questo per chi sarebbe potuto
diventare uno space cowboy un altro dei
personaggi di star wars è stato quasi un
segno
ho deciso di raccontare la loro storia
oggi non sono qui a parlarvi di questo
sono qui per raccontarvi come sono siano
bastati pochi i post in cui raccontavamo
di un samurai nero che era disposto a
tutto per aiutare i più deboli delle
periferie africane e per creare una
sorta di supereroe la comunità del
karate si è stretta intorno a lui e lo
sta aiutando in maniera concreta lo
stanno aiutando mandandogli creme solari
per proteggere la pelle degli albini e
lo stanno aiutando a costruire il mio
vero juventino organization un centro un
dojo per per albini dove questi possano
possono crescere senza il rischio di
essere mutilati ora se ho imparato
qualcosa negli anni in cui ho cercato di
raccontare la realtà è che l'unico modo
per sconfiggere una storia
a raccontarne una più grande e così il
nostro obiettivo è quello di portare un
albino ai prossimi mondiali di karate in
giappone sarebbe un segno enorme per
tutti i più deboli del continente
africano
non è facile anche perché adesso la
pandemia ha cambiato completamente tutto
e non dobbiamo ancora risolvere molti
problemi però siamo convinti di una cosa
che non si è mai fregato veramente
finché è una buona storia e qualcuno a
cui raccontarla
questa frase è di danny novecento il
personaggio di bari coprotagonista della
leggenda del pianista sull'oceano temi
all'iso il novecento era convinto che ci
fosse bisogno di qualcuno a cui
raccontarla una storia per non essere
fregati
oggi per noi è diverso oggi noi abbiamo
sempre qualcuno a cui raccontarlo ci
bastano due clic sul nostro smartphone
per raccontare tutto quello che ci passa
per la testa a chiunque
siamo una nuova era dal punto di vista
del racconto tutti filmiamo fotografiamo
tutto
e passiamo la maggior terre maggior
parte del nostro tempo a guardare quello
che sputano grano filmano gli altri
questo è ovvio che avrà un grosso
impatto nell'immaginario che verrà non
saranno più i film oi libri o il cinema
o per lo meno se lo saranno ancora ma ci
sarà uno spazio anche per i contenuti
dei social nell'immaginario di
riferimento che per la prima volta non
sarà deciso da potenti e visionarie come
è stato per gran parte della storia
dell'uomo ma sarà un'operazione
condivisa perché oggi possiamo cambiare
la percezione dei fatti con qualcosa che
abbiamo in tasca nel fino a qualche mese
fa sarebbe stato difficile credere
all'idea di un nemico misterioso capace
di mettere in ginocchio il pianeta
infatti molti noi non ci hanno creduto
però c'è stato un immagine che ha
cambiato tutto ed è stata scattata da
uno qualunque da un balcone al passaggio
dei camion militari che portavano le
salme fuori dalla città di berg
ha cambiato la percezione sulle prime ed
i covi 19 in italia perché ci siamo
accorti che la gente stava pulendo per
davvero darà così tanto qui ed era così
tanta che non c'era più spazio al
camposanto
adesso il fatto che ognuno di noi possa
cambiare il mondo
ho la percezione del mondo attraverso
qualcosa che ha in tasca a mio avviso
deve essere considerata al pari il
superpotere perché se tutti dicono tutto
noi possiamo libri di credere a chi
vogliamo e questo crea delle strane cose
tipo il ritorno dei terapisti secoli
dopo la morte di galileo se ben parker
aveva ragione ben parker allo zio di
dell'uomo ragno
anche noi come spiderman ogni volta che
postiamo qualcosa sui social abbiamo una
grandissima responsabilità perché da
quello che stiamo facendo dipenderà il
futuro del mondo che verrà dopo
l'immaginario del futuro e del mondo che
verrà dopo la pandemia che dovrà essere
diverso perché tra foreste che prendono
fuoco e ghiacciai che si sciolgono
rischiamo di non avere più un mondo che
raccontare grazie
[Applauso]